[Music]
do you want to know what it is you can
see it when you look out your window
when you watch your television the
matrix is everywhere it is all around us
even now in this game theory game theory
did it what game theory already did this
intro like practically last week dude
but we are the film channel we are the
ones who get the dibs hey man i don't
know what to tell you just wanted to say
it before the comments did um where was
i the matrix is everywhere it is all
around us even now in this
never mind the mood is all ruined feels
like i'm just retreading stuff that's
already been done oh man i was so
excited for this fourth installment in a
long-ended trilogy
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's always ready to see how
far the rabbit hole goes so have you
guys seen the new trailer for the matrix
4 between the return of the franchise a
new space jam movie and a new halo game
coming out 2021 has me asking what year
is it anyway watching this new teaser
trailer it seems pretty obvious to say
that the matrix resurrections has a lot
going on not that this is a franchise
that's ever been simple it's always been
built on big ideas and deep philosophy
wrapped in awesome fight scenes and
incredible visual effects and this new
iteration seems to be no different but
it also seems to be leaning very heavily
on imagery and concepts ripped from the
previous films and i mean they're not
even trying to hide that fact after all
these years to be going back to where it
all started back to the matrix so what's
going on is this just another soulless
cash grab of a franchise reboot well
it's certainly cash grab but i don't
think it's a soulless one believe me if
warner brothers wanted to make one of
those they have had plenty of
opportunities over the years but never
have one of the wachowskis has even
returned to be a writer and director of
the movie which says a lot about the
importance of this film in the overall
legacy in fact i think that the matrix
resurrections is
well resurrecting the franchise in a way
that is both in line with the canon of
the series and with its history of
making big statements about how humans
engage with technology ladies and
gentlemen after watching this trailer
more times than i care to count and
analyzing the franchise's past and
present i think i have the answers to
all of your biggest matrix 4 questions
while also having an idea of the plot
and what the overall meta-narrative is
planning to say about the modern state
of entertainment let me just tease it
this way neo is an actor this is his
agent and the whole previous matrix
trilogy is a movie series within this
new film that's a lot to unpack and
we're about to cover it all but before
we do make sure you take that red
subscribe button pill right below this
video to start seeing reality as it
truly is each and every week with a new
theory now let's begin to start off
let's answer one of the main questions
i'm sure everyone has regarding the
matrix resurrections how exactly are
characters like neo and trinity alive
and why is morpheus young again is that
even morpheus well for neo at least this
one has an easy answer despite the
christ-like imagery implying his death
in revolutions he never actually died in
the teaser we see two images both here
and here of neo being overseen by
machine drones in what is clearly meant
to be the real world notice the blue
color grading of the scenes and we know
that this is the same neo from the end
of the matrix trilogy how can we be sure
just take a look at his eyes they still
have the burn marks that he got towards
the end of matrix 3. the machines also
seem to be attaching tubes and wiring
performing some sort of laser surgery on
neo presumably so he can be reinserted
into the new matrix so easy enough
that's how neo's back but things get
more complicated when it comes to
trinity and morpheus because we know
they're both dead trinity dies near the
end of revolutions and morpheus well
morpheus needs a little bit more
explanation see the last we saw morpheus
he was singing some opera in the back of
a kia
and if that wasn't weird enough for you
that commercial is from 2014. the series
had been essentially dead for like 10
years talk about your dated references
isn't that right gary coleman
but of course that was just a commercial
it's not like it's canon or anything or
is it it isn't maybe no last time we saw
morpheus in the matrix films he was
staring in awe as the machines retreated
from zion is this real so why then would
i say that he's dead well to answer that
we have to look at the 2005 video game
the matrix online yeah we're digging
real deep for this one the game was
billed as an official continuation of
the matrix canon and its storyline which
is in fact called the continuing story
was signed off by the wachowskis
themselves now a lot happens in the
matrix online but one of the game's
major factions happens to be led by
morpheus who's returned to his
terroristic tactics after the machines
have refused to return nioh's body to
zion throughout the rest of the
storyline morpheus is hunted by a
mysterious masked figure known simply as
the assassin who lives up to his name
after he literally slides out of a small
vent on the side of a building and kills
morpheus yeah for a guy that survived
this his death in an alley is uh pretty
anticlimactic the game made some weird
choices
you know the dream you've dreamed it
that's it so matpat you're now saying
are you implying that both characters
have been resurrected hence given the
new movie's title a very on the nose
meaning yes yes i am these movies have
never been one for subtlety but i've got
proof and boy howdy did we dig deep for
this one you see the morpheus and
trinity we're about to see in matrix
resurrections are clones yup you heard
that right and believe it or not this
has precedent within matrix canon the
machines do indeed have the ability to
genetically engineer and clone humans
with specific traits for specific
purposes we know this based on a series
of obscure stories called the matrix
comics see way back when the very first
matrix movie was coming out in the late
90s warner brothers hired a bunch of
writers and artists to create comic
books and short stories to tie in with
the film these were released on the old
90s matrix website and while they were
primarily used to advertise the movie
they also filled out the new universe
with a ton of stories and lore that fans
could dig into and dissect these stories
later known collectively as the matrix
comics were all overseen and signed off
on by the wachowskis the one i want to
look at here today is a short story
called goliath in this story our unnamed
protagonist is revealed to be a
genetically engineered human with
enhanced speed strength and reaction
time a human that has been created by
the machines they've also designed him
to be interested in flying planes and
within the matrix the machines have fed
him lessons on flying ufo style
spacecraft so why would a bunch of
machines try to do all this well they
needed him out in the real world to fly
that same ufo into space and destroy an
alien spacecraft that's been thrown
asteroids at earth one of those
asteroids already destroyed australia
apparently and just as a quick reminder
yes the spacecraft that launches
asteroids at earth is a thing that
actually happened and is also canon with
the matrix anyway for as ridiculous as
that story might sound the reason i
bring it up is that it confirms that the
machines can engineer humans and can
implant personal interests and desires
into those humans as such it's not that
far of a stretch to assume that the
machines would be able to clone specific
people found within the matrix so if you
haven't connected the dots here i'm
saying that the machines have
genetically cloned both trinity and
morpheus and the teasers give us imagery
to back that up in several of the shots
that flash across the screen we see what
appears to be both trinity and a stasis
pod and the machines designing morpheus
new body both of these shots are also
clearly meant to take place in the real
world given the saturated blue color
grading this does however present us
with a small problem see in the teasers
we clearly see what appears to be
morpheus's awakening to the fact that he
is actually in the matrix in a scene
that's very evocative of when neo
touched the mirror in the first matrix
film we also see a couple of flashbacks
to the opening of the first matrix where
trinity escapes from the agents look at
the color grading of all these teaser
shots they're desaturated and they're
green just like the scenes that took
place within the matrix system from the
original trilogy and color grading is
really important with this franchise
notice how the world is over saturated
in these new trailers well at the end of
matrix revolutions we see that the newly
rebooted matrix at the end of that movie
has lost its iconic green color and
instead resembles the same look that
we're seeing pop up in resurrections so
that's a cool detail but if these shots
are from when clone morpheus discovers
he's in the matrix and when clone
trinity escapes from the agents and they
have the color grading of green how
could they be taking place after the end
of matrix 3 after the reboot of the
matrix well in goliath we see that the
machines can implant interests and
desires but they can also alter the
memories of anyone still hooked up to
the matrix so who's to say that they
couldn't create some believable scenario
that makes clone morpheus believe he
experienced an approximation of what the
real morpheus did years and years ago
when the matrix was color graded green
same with clone trinity in fact
comparing the shots from the teaser to
the original scene from the first film
you see that there are actually some
details that are off trinity is wearing
a different outfit in the resurrections
trailer is that just a movie mistake a
new creative decision or is that an
indication that these are approximate
memories of the event given to her by
the machines rather than the real exact
memories that the original trinity
actually experienced okay so we've
established how these characters are
alive but why why would the machines
even want to resurrect morpheus and
trinity or reawaken neo's powers in the
first place what is their endgame here
well to answer that let's take a look at
what we can discern about neo's life
here in the current iteration of the
matrix and i promise this is gonna be
relevant first off it seems like neo's
pretty darn wealthy in this current
version of his life he's seeing what
appears to be a nice therapist in a
fancy office he's taking a bath in what
looks to be an upscale home in san
francisco which is the second most
expensive city to live in in the u.s and
i'm pretty sure that that's gonna track
into the current version of the matrix
as well additionally he seems to be at
least somewhat friendly with obviously
wealthy people like this guy right here
and also check out this scene from one
of the teasers it clearly takes place in
a movie theater and the scene that's
being projected currently is straight up
a scene from the first matrix movie wait
what yeah the matrix is a movie that
exists within this newest iteration of
the matrix and it actually stars neo in
this world that is crazy amounts of meta
which got me thinking you see it's my
theory that in the newest iteration of
the matrix system thomas anderson keanu
reeves character is either an actor a
writer a director or maybe all three he
made the previous matrix films which in
turn skyrocketed his career to the level
of success that we see in these teasers
that's what this line after all these
years to be going back to where it all
started back to the matrix is actually
talking about thomas and this corporate
guy are going back to make more matrix
movies if i were to guess this new
character is neo's agent a literal
hollywood agent
quite a bit different than any of the
other past agents that neo had to deal
with they're going back to the franchise
not necessarily the physical place and i
can't believe that i'm about to say this
but if you look at how the matrix as a
computer system in the lore of these
movies operates the whole idea is not as
crazy as it sounds in fact it's already
been established if you manage to stay
awake through the architect portions of
the series he reveals that there are
multiple iterations of the matrix it's a
program that keeps restarting and he
explains that parts of past matrixes
live on as the folklore in more recent
versions of the matrix the first matrix
was a paradise everyone was happy all
the time nothing was ever bad and
nothing ever went wrong and some have
interpreted this to mean that it was
literally heaven as in angels and other
positive elements from real world
religions were present in this version
of the matrix memories from this version
of the matrix lived on in concepts like
the garden of eden from the christian
bible want something even more concrete
well we actually have solid proof in the
films that the second matrix had a huge
influence on folklore this was a
nightmare matrix that the machines made
based on the darker parts of human
history the first matrix i designed was
quite naturally perfect a triumph
equaled only by its monumental failure
as i redesigned it
based on your history to more accurately
reflect the varying grotesqueries of
your nature those grotesqueries ended up
being monsters like vampires and
werewolves and ghosts which roamed the
land in this version and many of those
programs managed to survive into modern
iterations of the matrix remember the
merovingian that creepy french guy from
the second movie well he has an army of
super strong programs that can pass
through walls or only be killed by
silver bullets my husband saved them
because they're notoriously difficult to
terminate how many people keep silver
bullets in their gun
and that's because they're literally
werewolves and ghosts i'm pretty sure
that the mayor of indian himself was a
vampire too but not 100 sure on that
anyway it follows that events from the
most recent iteration of the matrix the
one that we witnessed during the matrix
trilogy of films would also live on in
the pop culture of its next iteration i
mean it'd be pretty difficult to forget
agent smith shoving his hand into the
chests of pretty much everyone on the
planet to clone himself you
yes me
me too so why not disseminate this
information in a controlled way by
inserting it into the pop culture of
that world explicitly and who better to
use to distribute that information than
thomas anderson himself if you need even
more proof then take a look at this
scene from the teaser see that blurry
shape over there in the background that
looks to me an awful lot like an actual
prop that you can buy of a 3d model from
the scene where agent smith gets punched
in the face from matrix revolutions the
point of all of this is to say that in
this new matrix it's not so crazy to
think that thomas anderson is some big
shot writer actor whatever who helped
create and star in an in-universe movie
that dramatized the events of the
previous films this would also give new
context to a line from the first matrix
movie when cipher says that he wants to
be reinserted into the matrix as someone
important
like an actor
isn't that an interesting coincidence in
short the matrix resurrections is going
to be a meta commentary on rebooting
beloved media told through the soft
reboot of a piece of beloved media i
think it's gonna ask the difficult
question of whether it's better to give
an audience exactly what they want
exactly what they expect or is it
instead worth challenging them and their
expectations if you don't understand
what i mean well as an example just look
at the recent star wars films and their
reception is it better to produce
something like the force awakens a movie
that played it real safe story that did
nothing new but placated a majority of
the viewers it took important nostalgic
imagery and recycled it over and over or
is it better to produce something like
the last jedi a movie that challenges
its viewers and subverts their
expectations for better or worse the
story that takes the same iconic imagery
and turns it on its head taking it in a
wildly different direction but as a
result dividing the fan base i think the
machines are gonna try to take the force
awakens route with neo they're trying to
keep him sedated and happy feeding him
the story that he wants to hear so they
can keep him under their control they
know they can't suppress the memories of
what happened in the previous matrix
films from him forever its iconic
imagery is burned into his subconscious
just like it is with our cultural
subconscious they also know that they
can't operate the matrix without neo he
is hard-coded into the system as the
architect says in the matrix reloaded
you are the eventuality of an anomaly
which i've been unable to eliminate from
what is otherwise a harmony
of mathematical precision neo or the one
has to be in the matrix so the system
can function properly to give the humans
that want out a hope for a savior and in
a meta sense he also has to be in the
matrix so that we as the viewers have a
protagonist root for so the machines are
giving him and us exactly that they're
feeding neo a new story that he so
desperately wants to hear with the woman
that he wants to be with with the friend
he wants to fight alongside once more
going through the motions with similar
imagery to his past adventures perhaps
they've even set up new programs like
his media agent and his therapist to
help guide him subconsciously in that
direction notice how both of them have
blue motifs running through their
costumes and sets the agent's suit and
the therapist's glasses blue is the
color of the machines in this world
perhaps the machines are just hoping
that neo will once again merge with the
code in their system to keep the matrix
stable just like warner brothers needs
to keep that matrix franchise stable so
they can keep pumping out movies and
making money so they can spin it off
into a new hbo max show and make new
video games new merchandise new comic
books will they succeed will neo and the
audience be sedated by the same story
again well given the fact that i believe
the matrix resurrections is even asking
such a meta-textual question if i were a
betting man i would say no i think this
movie is going to surprise us and end
with a huge twist that sets up the
franchise to tell new stories will we
like it who knows that's kind of what
the machines want to find out but hey
that's just a theory a film theory
[Music]
you